our next guest is helping to raise
awareness about the importance of mental
health and suicide prevention suicide is
the second leading cause of death for
people aged 10 to 34 behind
unintentional injuries the CDC says
suicide affects black youth at twice the
rate as other racial groups New York
Jets defensive lineman Solomon Thomas
lost his sister Ella to suicide when she
was just 24 years old Thomas and his
family started a non-profit group called
the defensive line with the goal of
ending the youth suicide epidemic and
Solomon Thomas is here good morning good
to see you good morning good morning
thank you all for having me glad you're
here we're so happy to have you here
let's begin just with the impact of
Ella's suicide and how it has shaped
your approach you and your family to
mental health yeah you know uh kind of
for me growing up I wasn't always in
mental health it wasn't something that
was always on my Forefront or I kind of
was in the archaic mindset of being a
man you know tough to rip pushed through
don't cry don't show emotion and you
know that worked for me for a while you
know and until I lost my sister and I
went through uh my own depression I went
through my own journey and I tried to do
the same thing I tried to push through I
tried to fight through and um it just
led me to a darker place you know a
place where I didn't see the light a
place where I didn't want to wake up
anymore and um I had to get help and I I
went to therapy and I learned so much
more about mental health how to how to
cope with my emotions how to honor them
how to truly be a man how to cry how to
how to be there for myself and others
but also uh how to share my story and
from sharing my story I learned how big
of a promise is in our world and how
suicide is an epidemic in the USA and
it's the world in general I mean how
many people need help and they need to
hear stories and how vulnerability can
save people and really affect people and
just let people know that hey we're all
going through something so it's
important to talk about it to be
transparent so people know that they're
not alone so how hard was it number one
I'm so glad you're here I think this is
so important for men black or white just
men in particular because you are I like
that you use the word archaic to
describe your feelings so how hard was
it for you to talk about it and what did
you do to get to the point where you can
sit at the table and talk so publicly
about it yeah no it was really hard you
know it's not something that I always
wanted to do I didn't want to come on
national television and tell people my
deepest darkest times or about being
suicidal or about not wanting to be here
but you know from doing that you know I
I saw how many people struggled and I
saw how many people needed to hear this
message and that's what kept me going
and it's why I share my story you know
people need to know it's okay not to be
okay yeah it's okay to cry it's okay to
be anxious it's okay to be depressed
these are all emotions and experiences
of The Human Experience and we're all
kind of going to go through them at some
point in our life it's important to talk
about them so we can all kind of feel
human and feel normal because that's how
people can can be grounded and can
connect in that way we all know that
Solomon it's okay not to be okay but it
still is very hard to do and so I'm
trying to figure out what can we say
what can we do to show to people to say
to people that we must do this not only
is it okay but it's essential that we do
this yeah I think I think there are a
few ways I think first it's so important
to educate ourselves on Mental Health
you know understand the science of it
you know understand that hey you know
sometimes you're not getting enough
serotonin to your brain sometimes not
blocking enough cortisol you know to
understand these things are important
because then you can treat it like the
scientific disease that it is the
illness that it is the disorder that it
is because if we don't understand that
then you kind of left an archaic mindset
of oh it's just a feeling oh I can just
push through it um so I think that's
important first but then after that it's
important to ask a question how are you
doing but how are you doing right now I
know and I think when you followed up
with that like you really kind of hit
that human level like okay because when
people ask when I was struggling people
ask me how I was doing I would just say
I'm doing good I'm fine but that one
time someone asked me like how am I
doing really I just started bawling
crying because it really hit a level
where I was like okay they really want
to know how I'm doing and then you know
from that you can ask follow-up
questions you can see if they need help
and then if if it's to a point where you
need to ask this question it's important
to ask because and it's real are you are
you suicidal right now and those
questions are so important ask if that
bluntly yeah I I think it's really
important and the science that we get
from the American Foundation For Suicide
Prevention proves that it it lessens the
risk of suicide yeah so people have a
fear that if you ask that directly that
you're somehow going to plant the idea
from you we hear from other people that
that is the state of the science that
you should ask directly and get a direct
answer and and take action if you get uh
if you need to definitely yes sir uh so
you've got this Foundation this
nonprofit uh the defensive line Great
Name by the way talk to us a little bit
about the resources that are provided
definitely yeah so um in 2021 my film
and I we launched the defensive line
where our mission is to end epidemically
youth suicide especially if you're on
people of color by transforming the way
we connect and communicate over mental
health and we're doing this while we're
going into schools on business programs
uh Cleveland sports programs and we're
running our Suicide Prevention programs
where we're teaching uh mentors of Youth
mentors of co-workers um bosses uh CEOs
making sure they know how to have the
conversations mental health how to ask
the question how to how to talk about
feelings
um just how to create a safe environment
in their workplace in the locker room in
the classroom to where all your students
all your co-workers everyone around your
employees can feel comfortable talking
about mental health knowing the
resources around them knowing how to
look for warning signs knowing how to
see okay maybe he's not getting enough
sleep maybe his emotions are different
today maybe I should go check on him
this these kind of things that are small
things but can really change someone's
life and also save someone's life I
think they're very important and I know
we have to go but I have to ask you how
are we feeling about Aaron Rodgers we we
are loving Aaron Rodgers it's amazing in
the building uh great leadership you
know he's a guy who's commanding the
room
um you know he can coach o-line he can
coach a receivers coach of tight ends
running backs it's been really beautiful
seeing how he just knows a game of
football and can really put everything
together okay and like I said I know we
have to go but would you like me to fix
you up with anyone
single or available what's your time I'm
not asking for me I'm not I'm single and
available so you can fix me up
for help
it's been a great holiday Thomas
wonderful appearance
and the work you're doing is going it's
very important yeah it's important thank
you very glad you came